visual Trails or tracers are a great way
to visualize the patterns that we create
as we spin our POI they're beautiful
Dynamic and more than anything else they
help to clarify the patterns that we see
in our heads Drex here from Drex Factor
POI sharing with you the love of poi
spinning and flow Arts to benefit your
body and brain and today I want to count
down my top five favorite tricks that
look great with post-production Trails
on them but before we dive in I do just
want to give a quick shout out to the
Friends of the channel big thanks to
dark monk fire Mecca flow fests flow
toys juggling calling pyro Terra light
toys spin balls and Ultra POI for
helping to make the videos on this
channel possible you can learn more
about all of these awesome companies and
the work that they're doing to support
flow artists like yourself by checking
out the links that I have down in the
description of this video and special
thanks to the non-business Friends of
the channel Lane machinski and Becca
becklinen thank you both so much for
supporting my channel my work and my
mission
so I very regularly post videos that
include a little bit of post-production
magic to add trails to my POI as they
spin around I've done a video on the
techniques that I use for this that I
will go ahead and link to down in the
description but people really really dig
this and it's easy to understand why and
well I got a request to do more videos
that feature these kinds of trails and
as I was racking my brains trying to
think of another trick that would also
benefit from it I realized wait a second
there's a ton of tricks that look great
with them why not just put them all into
the same video so I do actually just
want to include a quick note here
because I think that the process of
selecting these tricks is actually way
harder than people might think it is
there are plenty of poi tricks that we
think of in terms of the patterns that
they produce but some of them require so
long to produce that pattern that
there's no amount of long exposure
photography or post-production Trails
you can do in a video editor that will
make that pattern clear in addition
there are some POI tricks that are
absolutely beloved but when you look at
them from the perspective of creating
these Trails they just look like
gibberish so whittling down to poy
tricks that are simple enough that they
can actually register with the audience
but still complex enough that they look
really cool it's actually more
challenging than you might think so here
we go my top five picks for my favorite
POI tricks that I think really benefit
from having those post-production Trails
on them
number one sea caps
yeah I know this is kind of a gimme
because the video that inspired me to go
down this path was one on ccaps but hey
it's because they work really well in
this way I don't think it's any
coincidence that the framework around
caps was developed right around the time
when Tech boy Spinners were going really
really hard on classifying different POI
patterns and the tricks around them in
particular ccaps represent this great
Tipping Point between being just complex
enough for people to geek out on while
also just simple enough that they read
very very cleanly to an audience and of
course I've done some pretty extensive
work on this channel cataloging and
categorizing all the different versions
of caps out there one video in
particular that hits I think pretty much
all the major bullet points I'll go
ahead and link to that down in the
description as well as up there in the
cards if you're watching on YouTube
trick number two anti-spin flowers in
Split Time same direction
so it just has to be said that anti-spin
flowers in general are kind of a perfect
fit for any kind of video or photography
devices that leave those long Trails
behind the petals that we get with
anti-spin flowers that kind of long
narrow form that they have just there's
something about it that's so pleasing to
the eye and Performing them in Split
Time same direction I would argue is
probably the best version of this trick
not only are they being performed in
such a way that you always have this
very even and symmetrical feel with the
flowers but they also lack the problems
that you tend to have with together
opposite or split time opposite flowers
where part of the image is just slightly
offset from the rest of it this just
feels nice and balanced and super
satisfying I'm pretty sure it was
surreal back in the day who classified
different timing and directions in terms
of the visual picture that they create
for the audience and when it comes to
anti-spin flowers having a central point
of balance that the flowers happen
around and is just kind of perfect for
creating a visual effect for the
audience bonus points of course if you
do the version of this that involves
spinning this flower super duper fast so
fast in fact that people might not even
need post-production effects to see the
trails at all and then out of nowhere
stop and reverse directions I have seen
both Yuda and Mel pull this out in
performances to incredibly dramatic
effect love it
number three the triquetra versus static
spin anti-brid
yeah it's it's me so you just had to
know that there was going to be at least
one anti-brid on this list right so this
is a trick that in my mind positively
begs for the trails treatment not only
is it one of those tricks that requires
you to go just a little bit faster than
your comfort zone in order to keep it
together but also too it just feels so
balanced and satisfying seeing these two
shapes emerge together I honestly think
that this is the most photogenic of all
of the ant hybrids not only does it have
a good balance between complexity and
simplicity but also too it looks really
cool to perform whether you see the
trails or not
trick number four the toroid anti-ben
pentagram or just toroid pentagram
yes it's me so this list was going to
have a tour right on it as well so
assuming
but legit this one looks really cool so
I actually first saw this being
performed with a set of sock POI and I
just did not get it at all it looked to
me as though somebody was going back and
forth between a two beat weave and a
corkscrew and I just did not understand
for the life of me why that would be so
interesting and then the first time I
saw it with long exposure photography
all of a sudden it clicked for me most
POI tricks we are working with curves
and trying to put together very very
specific patterns that will work with
those curves regardless of how straight
the hand path between different parts of
it is with toroids on the other hand we
actually get to play with straight lines
as we're bending the POI back and forth
and there's no shortage of really
awesome and eye-catching polygons that
are only possible if we can move the POI
back and forth in a straight line
toroids are a great fit for this and the
pentagram in particular is something
that is both simple enough that you can
pull it off relatively easily as well as
complex enough that it's kind of
unexpected affected and cool this is
also one of those tricks that definitely
benefits from performing it a little bit
faster than you normally might which can
make the planes just a little bit
sketchy but if you can find that balance
point oh it's so worth it I'm not gonna
lie this one has shown up in my holiday
cards for years now and probably will
continue to for many many years to come
here's to this toroid alright so before
I share with you my number one pick I
have a quick favor to ask if you've come
this far in the video it probably means
that you're into POI tricks and if
that's the case I make lots of videos on
those please subscribe to my channel and
leave this video a like so you can help
the channel out as well as know when
I've uploaded my latest video and now my
number one pick for my favorite trick
that benefits from having these long
exposure Trails or post-production work
done on them
number one the Mercedes
yeah come on y'all had to know that this
was coming right I can remember a time
when absolutely everybody I knew in the
POI world had a long exposure photograph
of this POI trick as their head shot it
actually kind of made things difficult
at fire festivals because people would
introduce themselves to me and I would
have to puzzle out who the heck they
were because they didn't really look
like a Mercedes I mean all the pieces
are really there among POI hybrids this
is one of the easier ones to produce you
have the tension between the extension
on the outside and the anti-spin flower
in the middle and of course it resembles
something that we are already familiar
with the Mercedes of course where it
gets its name from so yeah you kind of
can't beat it even better the Mercedes
combines together with another item on
our list that is ccaps to create a
really eye-catching combo that was one
of my first and very favorite ways to
break apart two different Tech POI
tricks in my first couple years of
spinning and that's why it's my pick for
my favorite POI trick that benefits from
long exposure photography or from post
production Trails but how about you out
there what are your favorite POI tricks
with those long Trails attached to them
was there something that should have
been on my list and wasn't was there
something that did make my list that you
think yeah maybe that wasn't such a
great pick leave me your comments and
let me know
foreign
[Music]
would not be possible but not for the
kind support of all of these awesome
people right here these are my flow
patrons over on patreon they and the
people listed down in the description
helped make this video and all the
videos on this channel possible thank
you one and all for your very generous
support and if you out there watching
want to become supporters but you're not
currently here's how you can do that
head on over to patreon.com
drexfactorpoi and sign up I'll leave a
link to it down in the description as
well as up in the cards if you are
watching on YouTube there you can get
access to a whole host of awesome
rewards and even better you'll be
helping me out in my mission to bring
POI spinning and flow Arch to the whole
wide world and help people connect with
their brains and their bodies go check
that out please and thank you if you'd
like to check out some of my other
videos on the top five POI tricks of
various sorts I'm going to go ahead and
leave a link to a playlist of those down
in the description as well as up here on
screen if you are watching on YouTube
also YouTube thinks that you might like
this top video here because it's quite
popular amongst other people viewing my
channel so maybe give that a look as
well either way thanks so much for
watching make sure to get out and flow
today and I'll see you with a new video
real soon
peace